let's see if we can use our existing
factoring skills to factor 30 x squared
plus 11x y plus y squared I encourage
you to pause the video and see if you
can handle it yourself
now the first hint I will give you and
this might kind of open up what's going
on here is to maybe rearrange this a
little bit we could rewrite this as y
squared plus 11x Y plus 30x squared and
my whole motivation for doing that it
there are ways to factor in a quadratic
where your first coefficient your
coefficient on this first term is
something other than 1 but we haven't
seen that yet and so rearranging it this
way this kind of got is a little bit
more into our comfort zone now our
coefficient is a 1 on the y squared term
so now we can start to think of our
think think of this in the same form
that we've looked at some of the other
factoring problems can we think of two
numbers whose product is 30x squared and
whose sum whose sum is 11 X notice 11 X
is the coefficient on Y we have Y
squared some coefficient on Y and then
in terms of Y some you know this isn't
in any way dependent on Y so if you knew
if you one way to think about this if
you knew what X was then this would be a
quadratic in terms of Y and that's how
we're really thinking about it here so
can we find two numbers whose product is
30x squared and two numbers whose sum is
the coefficient on this Y term right
here whose sum is 11x so let's just
think about all of the different
possibilities if we were just thinking
about two numbers whose product was 30
and whose sum was 11 we would be
thinking of 5 and 6 5 times 6 is 30 5
plus 6 is 11 and some trial and error
you could have tried 3 & 10 well that
would have been 13 would be their sum
you could try 2 and 15 that wouldn't
have worked
you could you could but 5 & 6 does work
here so we've already seen that multiple
times so 5 & 6 5 & 6 would work for 30
but we have we have 30 x squared so what
if we have 5x and 6x
well 5x times 6x is 30x squared
and 5x plus 6x is 11 X so this actually
works so then our our factoring or our
factorization of this expression is just
going to be y plus 5 X y plus 5 X times
y plus 6 X y plus 6 X and I'll leave it
up to you to verify that this does
indeed when you multiply it out equal
this up here